as a son of a Python you know that the
pipe of the story is a very very
intriguing woman lots of ups and downs
what made you want to
specifically on Graham Chapman I mean my
memories of Graham were quite vague and
my strongest memory is actually going to
his memorial and one of the reasons why
it was my strongest memories is because
afterwards we went and did a xx party
and I got very drunk and I think I was
quite young at the time that was
probably the first time I got drunk
underage drinking by then and so by then
we've grown not being around and these
past 20 odd years he's been forgotten
about a bit and we just really wanted to
celebrate his achievements all the
things that he did done and has done and
get some of the nice things that and
just show him off a little bit really
and I'm Terry let's move on to you the
film paints Graham as a very complex
individual did you ever really
understand him during your time and no I
don't think I did actually I think he
didn't understand himself really I think
he was looking for who he was and you
know he found himself as a homosexual
but then I think you know David David
David Sherlock says that actually he
would probably gone straight in the end
find himself as an alcoholic he styled
himself as an alcoholic but then he gave
up alcohol just like that but I think he
was in search of whoever he was did this
film eliminate any aspects of his
character you perhaps hadn't well I
think it is only seeing this film that I
that it strikes me that that's what he
was doing
yeah writing to find himself and Michael
I'm gonna head off the inevitable
question at the past
during this film with Terry in the booth
doing all these voices and getting Jon's
involved and Terry Gilliam's involved is
this as close to a Python reunion as
we're going to get where he is in Spain
we all reunited in different parts of
the world it's a bit of a homage to to
gray because he was he was remarkable
man I remember before we even did Python
Terry Knight had watched at last the
1948 show and John Cleese and Graham
Chapman and Chuck Taylor marty Feldman
others did and we're really impressed by
Graham's sort of stillness the fact he
didn't really seem to act very hard and
he was absolutely sort of your eye was
drawn to him who just was there the
father the way Graham was generally yeah
because the first time I ever saw him
was the Windom theater when they were
doing Cambridge circus and we were doing
another review in the Oxford review it
was called for asterisks it didn't have
a name it was called it we called it and
we called into the Windom theater
whether they were doing a matinee the
Cambridge circus was being a matinee and
and I couldn't take my eyes off Graham
because I could see what everybody else
was doing they were being funny you know
they were acting and Bill Oddie and Tim
brooke-taylor and John Cleese were being
funny but Graham looked like he walked
in off the street and was just what was
supposed to be there and I think that
made him our lead actor and that's why
we cast him in as Arthur in the Holy
Grail and as Brian's life O'Brien
because he was our lead performer and he
was just himself on screen let's move on
down through HF and Ben the mean where
was this always going to be an animated
movie and was it tough to condense a
life into 90 minutes and yeah we decided
we had to use animation because
brain was sadly and available to to take
part in his own life story partly the
tapes that we found in goods yeah I mean
the the book that it's based on it goes
off into fantastic flights of fantasy
and he takes you down kind of dark
alleys and up into space and it's a kind
of lot lots of madness really and so
it's probably something that we could
only do in animation you know unless
we've been filming in space and and
inside his mind and and all those other
crazy places that he takes us to but we
we wanted to use different it was always
it part of the plan to use lots of
different styles of animation it'll
reflect not just those different places
that he goes but also the different
tones of the humor some of it is quite
dark the the the bit in Los Angeles at
the end is quite cool but it's quite
detached so we were able to match the
stars of the animation to the styles of
his writing and the humor hopefully what
was the second part of the question I
was gonna I was gonna spend I mean you
found those types of Graham there's
audio tapes was that a godsend which
point in the production did you did you
find us I I mean probably Jeff yes I did
he actually found them and brought them
to us yeah I went up to see David
Sherlock who's been mentioned Graham's
partner hoping actually to do a
documentary about Graham and hoping that
David might have you know home movies or
something that could be materials for
documentary sadly he didn't but in the
course of that conversation he mentioned
that Graham had been into a studio in
Los Angeles Harry Nilsson's studio and
over two nights recorded the entire well
two and a half hours of his
autobiography as a kind of early
audiobook before those things existed
really so David knew of the tapes
existence but it took me a little while
to track them down and then I pitched it
as a documentary with Graham narrating
his own life story from beyond the grave
with some bits of animation in which
thankfully the BBC turned down
and at that point I walked into Berlin
Benz with some tapes of Graham's voice
and some bits of animation and we we
just done the exhaustively endlessly
exhaustive documentary series on Monty
Python called always the truth so we
didn't we we really didn't want to do a
documentary a talking heads I don't
think you wanted to do any more like
what you are now but when we said Terry
Jones would you like to play Graham
Graham Chapman's mum that the sort of
the Eureka moment was when we realized
that we that we could just make it as a
as an animated film and we could bring
in the other voices and we could cut we
could edit his voice because we were
lucky because you when you listen to the
book he does perform in the book he
performs I mean not all the time but
most time he performs and bizarrely only
performs his own lines so he must have
known this was going to happen he was no
interest in doing anybody else's so so
yes so that was the sort of moment that
we just we thought let's let's try and
get this Manor to try and get this done
fantastic and and Justin we've discussed
already there's many many styles of
animation in this movie how hard was it
to keep her attract things and keep
things relatively inconsistent to people
well a project like this only comes
along once in a blue moon and it was an
honor really with all the animation
companies to work on it that to have a
we started with 90 companies and in the
way met them and interviewed them and
between us all really what came down to
who really wanted to do it the whites
and their eyes and they were really
excited about they involved and the
creative collaboration the project was
really unique and quite pioneering and
the fact that no one had done
stereoscopic before in the film one
person that's Jeff keep saying who
actually lied to it said you've done it
so well so as far as keeping everyone in
control I think everybody has really
wanted to do it everyone was so honored
and so want to be a part of it and to be
able to hold up things like the original
shoe from the life of Bryan and be
around this wonderful memorabilia and
tell the story of this person and
sandal-wearing decided to take your
sandals off no it was a project that
that from one little man in Oxford did a
sequence to a big company in New York
tear sequence so it really is a lovely
branch across all the animation
companies and I think that's good legacy
to animations and is that a German
grandpa by the way as well did we do we
did have his tobacco pouch and so far
but can't remember where they had one of
these straight pipes or the cone by the
curved run this big question for mr.
Palin you once used the determine
unconstructive silliness referring to
the Pythons humour how much RAM someone
was a part of this well great I think
Graham was perhaps sillier than all of
us it didn't appear to me appeared to be
very straight and and rather serious
about things but I feel that very often
Graham would would be silent for a long
period in writing and then after about
half and I would save something could be
a Norwegian blue or something like that
and immediately you've got something
there which no one else would have
thought of he did have a way of going to
you know they're really that the
silliest ideas and yet I say he was a
very sort of seemed a very serious man
so I think he yeah he was very very
important to the construction or
deconstruction all the silliness
certainly of Python and he appreciated
silliness he loved it which other
members of the team didn't quite as much
John quite like being silly but those
appointments stopped being silly but
especially about 3:27 you say lemon
curry and betty miles and that's it yeah
I was when we were filming in Glen Cove
for Life of Brian and here Graham Cody
Graham sorry
yeah it was just fun man I went to bed
early being the nice one to group and
heard in the corridor ahead Graham but
remastering
breaking more thin than the second night
comes a better milestone I'm a mole
removed they removed them so on the
third morning I said granny through mine
it's just I was trying to get sleep can
you just keep so the next night there
was silence no Betty Marsden at all and
I woke up in the morning little slip of
paper pushed under my door and I said
Betty miles do so he was silly question
for Terry and Michael we've heard about
the tapes but how was it for you hearing
the tapes for the first time was it like
a voice from beyond the grave and and
did it inspire a lot of trip down memory
going like that last answer I guess no
but it was just natural I felt just very
natural to have gram grams presence in
the in the studio and when we were
recording the voices you just felt what
it used to be like I didn't talk up a
hospital strings at all but very I mean
brilliant because I think large
autobiographies run the best books about
Python if not the best parties by short
there's because all lies and yet within
the lines a lot of the truths and it's a
very very funny book there's a bit where
he comes off the plane after the
Canadian tour we all did we went to Los
Angeles and Graham a drunk an awful lot
and he got to this hotel and he was so
pissed he would do first thing was ring
up and asked them whether he'd checked
in or not and if he was in a group or
not and they told me us and then he said
well I'd like to I want to go my
favorite restaurant in LA please send a
limousine
collect me they said are you sure he
said yes are you sure you want a
limousine to take you to this restaurant
and Graham said yes I do you know I mean
thank you very much they've got quite
testy about it and got into the
limousine and the restaurant just across
the road so there's some very it's a
very funny book and it was great to hear
Graham read it really yeah I thought it
did bring him back and I think it's
brilliantly interwoven into the film
it's it I don't think it Duncan really
worked without that voice of gray
everything all the way through and it's
rather nice to hear him I'd never heard
him read the book
Michael you truly are a Globetrotter you
seemed have been everywhere when you go
on your travels around the world are you
astonished at the popularity of Python
and how RIT how far it reaches are you
been used by it
are you gratified by it what's what's
the effect that it has on it well I'm be
mused because I mean we did expect
Python to last longer than about two or
three years from me wrote that was the
life of a television program then you
just and nothing was stored and kept
it's not like now you've got lots of
different media and then YouTube and all
that so I think the very fact that
Python still survives and did so by the
skin of his teeth you know how Adele who
was our video editor
announced that they were going to the
BBC we're going to wipe the tapes the
first series in a month in a month's
time
and so we smuggled the the tapes out of
the BBC and with Howard Dells connivance
and recorded on a Philips VCR and I
thought that that's going to be the only
archive of the of the shows but
fortunately it then sold to the to the
the states and to the
PBS and states public broadcasting
station states and so that we were
rescued actually we were very lucky
because we were we went out the first
week that BBC one went into color and so
otherwise we'd have been made in black
and white and and I don't think the
shows of lasted as long as they've heard
there's an interesting thing because I
was in Croatia filming and talking to
people who yep in yugoslavs
the whole part of Yugoslavia and I
remember that we sold Python to
Yugoslavia very early on we also
actually the first cell phone service to
Pakistan
apparently was a total mistake they just
they thought it was a circus you know
and after 13 shows where the you know
where the acrobats the clown's you know
what's one thinks that they give their
money back but Yugoslavs took it and and
met some people in Croatia so beloved
Python because marshal Tito aloud is
actually quite liberal in some ways and
he allowed people to watch foreign
television show so python was current
there and it was kind of used as a Badge
of Courage if you if you watch Python
talked about Python you could relate
your own sort of discontent with your
own government by saying you watch
Python so it was it meant something they
kind of rallied around and laughed at
their own authority figures through
Python I thought that was quite
interesting you're often being a new
project you've been asked by twist three
minutes ago but this movie proved that
it can be vibrant happened wonderfully
by animation and sound recordings and we
know that Tupac hologram appears in
front of full stadiums so perhaps there
is a new technology that will enable no
a new tool and you put a new project
perhaps another round at the Hollywood
Bowl
using that technology this morning and
to create so is this really the closest
that we'll get to but I tell you walking
on absolutely anything we should also
bring there by a big part of to go
together aren't you
you won't live down there in your film
absolutely anything yes no that's that's
a film right written with Gavin Scott
it's done into violence I mean the I
understand that it has been published
but the Pythons will donate their voice
yes well they were planning to do we
were planning to have the Titans voicing
the aliens it's about a man who gets
magical powers and can suddenly make
anything happen
and the aliens giving this these powers
they intersect the Voyager spacecraft
but anyway there is nothing really to do
with getting quite interesting science
and Michael you haven't signed your
contact to this project yet but I'm
finding no said to Terry I'd do a voice
yeah do that but nothing's actually
signed and I mean the press do leap on
the slightest chance
nope I was all together for a reunion
someone as easy as that Mike Medavoy
Phoenix Pictures told me that he was
trying to sell it as a Python film he
spent two years trying to sell it but
Bill and Ben are going to make it in
enjoyed villain been single well double
handedly keep Python going
people have forgotten long ago finding
odd things onto the desk or bits of
paper than be used to sort of wait
chairs down if someone wants to produce
a new Python project nowadays what would
be who would be easier to recruit the
stone that sees to be firm Chapman or
occasionally Lent
a question for Terry and Michael how
constrained
have you felt by Python is it something
you've wanted to escape at times and
Bill what what is what was it like
growing up around
- open doors for me personally and I've
always enjoyed doing Python so I enjoyed
it at the time and it's it's I don't
feel I've never felt constrained I think
it it's great that it survives and I
mean we did find a lot of it funny it's
rather nice to find 50 years later or
whatever it is 40 years later that other
people still find it funny having this
humor doesn't change we had and also it
was I mean I found working on Python
sometimes tricky but it was what it
taught you was supposed to be you know
preserve your independence and your
control that's a big thing that Terry's
always been very strong about you know
let's make sure that we hang on to our
work as much as possible that was never
that easy other people wanted to you
know sell out or whatever but but we've
all it really taught me that it's very
very important if you've made something
to do it in your own way and then try
and keep control of it as much as
possible so in that way I learned a lot
from
I think territory mentioned that Python
opened doors for that and it means in
fact all of the five surviving pythons
have had a kind of second life a second
career as a result of Python but one of
the reasons we want to make this film is
the gren really never really had that he
died aged 49 he never really had that
second career so hopefully we're
bringing him back to we're giving him
some kind of recompense for that growing
up going up as within Python night it I
think was a bit of the Golden Age of
being famous really because you didn't
have so much interest intrusion by the
press and and also we didn't actually
there wasn't when I was at school and
and you know who started understanding
about people being famous and things
it wasn't on television and there wasn't
DVDs and he didn't have the internet you
didn't have access to it so he dad
wasn't actually the famous parent at my
school the famous parent in my school
was he was the teacher in schools teach
from Grange Hill he was the famous kid
because he was on television and and and
in a kid's program as well so he
everyone knew him and and so I mean so I
think what would have Breyer made of the
film I mean how would he comment on it
if he saw it
I think it's a it's it's a very exciting
film actually to watch and it's it's
very dark in places I think you like the
solid structure of it now how many
different animation 17 different
storyboard rather quickly rule 17 I like
that he would I think it really really
appreciate it probably take him back to
the days when he drank a lot on here
truly this finding sequence about
meaning the DTS in the morning that's
not brilliantly done but I think you'd
probably find that quite harrowing but
as a doctor and he was a doctor I was
interested in medical matters he would
probably find that quite you know he
would be interested in that the medical
point of view we did the life of Brian
he took me upstairs and showed me this
huge suitcase that was packed full of
medicine and and he said and so every
every day after filming there was a line
up the outside his hotel room with
people that wanted to be cured of
something
you